alors que l'été commence dans pile poil
2 semaines et que les températures
grimpent en flèche partout en france la
ministre de la transition écologique
amélie de montchalin flippe un peu à
l'idée que tout le monde mette la clim à
fond n'achetez pas de la climatisation
alors mal à montchanin nous dit ces
dérèglements climatiques et six
adhérents climatique parasco si on
utilise trop limpide le prêt de ses
systèmes de climsec elles sont trop
gourmandes en énergie et donc elle
accentue le réchauffement climatique
sauf que le réchauffement climatique
bahassa donne chaud et quand on a chaud
on veut mettre la clim bref c'est un peu
le serpent qui se mord la queue tout ça
du coup reste à savoir si les français
sont prêts à subir les fortes chaleurs
pour sauver la planète au pire ils
peuvent toujours le prendre avec le
sourire comme notre match
[Applaudissements]
prêt e à couper la petite pour sauver la
bête moi j'ai discuté mais qu'un médecin
qui m'avait dit cette phrase qui m'avait
quand même interloqué m'avait dit quand
il fait froid on se chauffe ben oui
d'accord mais quand il fait chaud
si oui alors séparées qu'ont comme ça
mais c'est tellement taire ses charges
et élémentaires alors vous seriez prêt à
couper la clé boucicaut mais moi j'aime
les ambiances chaudes les ambiances un
peu moite
elle c'est pas pour sauver la sienne
celle pour qui
sait ce qu il a dit n'avoir très bien ma
vie mais
je pense qu'elle a raison effectivement
c'est un cercle vicieux donc il faut de
temps en temps se responsabiliser au
fond la clim alors les plus pessimistes
annoncent annonce quand même dans
certains pays 50 degrés
casino de calais on peut pas vivre sous
50 de glen
voici comment ils font les bédouins dans
le désert et ses bas ils se protègent 50
degrés
elle reste pas dans le désert ne connais
pas ni qu'offre la clim n'existe pas
depuis si longtemps donc dû vivre ici on
peut sauver la planète en arrêtant la
climatisation c'est la foule acclame
vivait sans micro ondes aussi je suis
pas sûr qu'ils soient prêts
alors là le haut niveau
avant l'été en calèche donc
spécial dans leur ville
[Applaudissements]
carney
oui à la cnim pas bien sûr c'est de ce
bacille m'attendant à main et mon nom
bien connu la création de la clim
mais c'est toujours pareil on la
ministre nous demande de faire un effort
on va le faire sans doute certains mais
la sncf a donc c'est bien de là bah oui
voilà spécialistes les trains sont
beaucoup trop plume attisé on se caille
moi j'ai fait dévaler des voyages avec
uniquement un foulard sur la tête à m et
alors on me dit ah bah oui mais on peut
blesser on peut pas plus donc voilà donc
il y en a marre que ce soit nous pauvres
citoyens qui faisons des efforts et au
dessus ça ne suit pas donc moi je le
ferai mais je m'entraîne et 50 décès
parce que moi aussi j'aime les endroits
très froid l'avion la chose est que une
habitude plus une habitude plus voilà
sur les français ça fait ça fait
beaucoup et donc c'est très bien vous
même il faudrait que le ministère de la
transition écologique nous disent par
exemple je sais pas moi 20 chose à faire
pour que ça ait du sens et pas juste la
clim et après la clinique le joker je
l'éteins foule dense avec donc pas de
soucis pour ça mais il faudrait que les
gens se responsabilisent
basque a pas de petite amie pourriez
vous passer de la climatisation moi je
n'ai pas la maison de millions et de
millions aujourd'hui où il est très bien
d'habitude
[Applaudissements]
c'est beau
a
nice je crois va disparaître
je ferai tout ce qui est en mon pouvoir